Gary fence okay bro I'm going to come
after you now
are you [ __ ] douche what was that yeah
I can hear you moan your douche I know
it great I refill my [ __ ] oil [ __ ]
you fear if he appears I'm gonna slam
his [ __ ] face
better run like I've got that [ __ ] like
I always do
kids are there is no cogwheels here
and we got a refill of oil wait I got it
it's I bet it's underneath
as its this is work
it's got to be something I thought they
were going to be underneath that would
be awesome if I sold up busty doesn't
seem like it I don't know how you dig
uh community rocks
or did I do that I'm confused right now
alright alright
dude the shell [ __ ] haunts me alright
you go you go
I mean it's still the screen still
covers most of it I was going to think
about streaming it that's why I changed
it promise
all right
so we need to find on cogwheels maybe
where there were some more upstairs
but it is still more laggy another likes
for you that's one [ __ ] you yeah alright
one more
there it is no don't waste my yeah it
was there I saw you
and then when I put them to place the
monster will be all the lights will go
out and I will piss my panties as usual
even though I'm ready for it it still
scares me that's why I don't like this
game
usually when you play a scary game or
whatever there we go it stops being as
scary as the first minutes of you
playing it this game has been a [ __ ]
nightmare from the first second to the
most and apparently I'm not even close
to finishing
so that's [ __ ] great I was hoping I
was downing the after the [ __ ]
elevator but no the game continues what
else [ __ ] work do you need go down
the elevator well I really don't want to
go
what-whatever miss
oh yeah that was he like
this
there we go
there's nothing the burner
I need to fill in the code
that's what this was thought it was like
my growths diarrhea or something
all right I wonder how many it's kind of
pick three years here is always a good
number
so many hits you need to kill bosses in
the old days [ __ ] you Shelley
due to shallow
and we're good let's head on the burner
and now the elevator should be working
all right so let's have down the creepy
[ __ ] elevator it's why the [ __ ] not
in this game as yeah
I hate you thank you oh [ __ ] you do
that's cool
oh they're one of those now that I do I
just said [ __ ] stop a pairing front
of me no I scream like a girl
I want to read that he flipped through
the book of Monarch looking it looking
for etchings and counted nine different
kings I'll read the red
Oh creepy cutscenes by the [ __ ] up I
feel like this is one way
one way trip and I feel like it's gonna
be really dark down there because
otherwise I'm gonna let me refill my
[ __ ] oil I guess it's better than no
oil at all but I guess I'm gonna have an
episode here even though it doesn't
really fit because I feel like this is a
good part to end an episode so you're in
part whatever